marine biseau bonjour merci d'avoir
accepté notre invitation directe sur rt
france alors cette question comment
explique-t-on la détresse psychologique
des personnes âgées en maison de
retraite
alors en fait c'est très simple bien
évidemment les personnes qui sont anti
rentrer chez nous en maison de retraite
on peut pas les comparer avec des
personnes qui sont chez eux même s'ils
ont parfois le même âge les gens qui
rentrent en maison de retraite
il rentre pour des raisons très précises
soit parce qu'ils ont des maladies qui
se sont dégradées soit parce qu'ils ont
des dépendances de plus en plus forte
aux besoins de soins techniques ne
peuvent plus assurer les infirmières à
domicile donc bien évidemment c'est
d'ailleurs écrit dans le rapport qui a
été publié par la drees on peut en fait
c'est des personnes qui sont plus
fragiles psychologiquement et donc aussi
psychologiquement donc ça explique une
grande partie des chiffres que vous avez
mentionné juste avant alors là m à redon
ali d'après vous est ce qu'il faudrait
donc privilégier les dispositifs d aide
à domicile
alors évidemment aujourd'hui dans le
secteur ya un consensus en c'est ce que
tout le monde tous les acteurs de la
gériatrie ans au consensus c'est à dire
il faut respecter le désir des personnes
de rester vieillir chez elles le plus
longtemps possible et toutes les
solutions de maintien à domicile se sont
beaucoup développées ces dernières
années vous avez tous les médias de
l'esa dans des services de soins et
aides à domicile d accueil du jour des
plateformes de répit
des équipes mobiles qui accompagne les
gens homicide sur la problématique
donc tout ça ça s'est beaucoup
développée et vous avez des initiatives
innovantes pour le favoriser le plus
possible mais dans certains cas c'est
plus possible de rester à domicile pour
des raisons que je vous ai expliqué tout
à l'heure un ou parfois des ruptures de
parcours le deuil de l'étang principal
le conjoint qui décède et qui s'occupait
de la personne à domicile et c est donc
dans ces cas là en fait c'est nécessaire
d'avoir ces établissements les ehpad qui
peuvent répondre aux besoins de ces
personnes c'est un maillon nécessaire de
du vieillissement aujourd'hui en france
alors selon vous pourquoi cette
situation est plus marquée dans les
institutions publiques que dans les
établissements privés
alors là je sais qu'en plus ça a été
discuté par par les représentants des
organismes privés donc là vous êtes dans
un établissement public
je suis je suis fonctionnaire donc
je suis pas forcément la mieux placée
pour en parler entourant en tout cas en
tout cas voilà les établissements je
pense le public privé et à but lucratif
ou non font leur maximum pour
accompagner les résidentes qui sont
confiées à eux de leur mieux
après peut-être qu'effectivement on
parle aussi parfois du personnel n'est
pas tout à fait différent suivant les
établissements
je pense que c'est pas forcément le les
faits majeurs qu'il faut retenir de
trappes arenc en tous les cas selon vous
est-ce qu'il faut repenser et
l'accompagnement des seniors est ce
qu'ils sont devenus les oubliés de notre
société
alors c'est certain que c'est un sujet
qu'on laisse de côté
trop souvent on a une grosse des grosses
réformes et des contre manifestations
depuis 2016 et on est toujours dans la
tente de la loi grand âge qui n'est pas
cannes qui n'a toujours pas abouti c'est
vrai que nous on est en attente
les directeurs d'établissements comme
les professionnels de beaucoup de
réponses par rapport aux enjeux qui se
jouent aujourd'hui
et du coup j'en profite pour vous dire
aussi que les résidents qu'on accueille
lyon n'est pas comme je l'expliqué son
sont plus fragiles physiquement et
psychologiquement on l'a vu dans ce
rapport
et du coup ils ont besoin autour d'eux
de professionnels formés de médecins
infirmières psychologues et soignants et
en fait c'est ça qu'il faut retenir de
ce rapport c'est que c'est bien parce
qu'ils sont plus fragiles et qui sont
souvent effectivement peut-être plus
dépressifs ou qu'ils ont moins de faire
des trous de l'appétit des troubles du
sommeil qu'il faut auprès d'eux de
personnel compétent à fourmies il faut
là où il faut nous garantir à ces
établissements
les moyens de pouvoir accompagner ces
personnes avec leurs besoins en fait
parce que on est un autre maillon copine
sim est un maillon qui sont nécessaires
merci beaucoup
marine biseau d'avoir répondu à nos
questions je rappelle que vous êtes
directrice adjointe de la maison de
retraite de la fondation gourlay bon
temps